nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis une femme heureuse et accompli
j'ai la chance de me réveiller les
matins non pas pour aller travailler
mais pour vivre de simples petites
choses de la vie
mais remplissent de bonheur comme les
sur yon d'un enfant l'odeur du pain
frais le matin
la floraison d'un arbre est encore
regardé les couchers de soleil avec mon
être aimé mais ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas
ma passion pour les voyages et les
langues m'a amené à parcourir le monde
de la colombie au brésil des états unis
à la france de la suisse au nicaragua
avant de poser mes valises un nouvelle
calédonie pendant plus de dix ans j'ai
eu la chance de fréquenter les grandes
écoles et puis je construis ma carrière
entre les cabinets d'avocats les
organisations internationales et les
grandes entreprises
et j'ai pu constater que toutes ces
organisations ont une chose en commun
c'est qu'elles répondent à une logique
pyramidale un modèle d'organisation
hyper hiérarchisée où la prise de
décision s'est fait du haut vers le bas
un système où la performance
individuelle est encouragée et même
célébré être performant rester
travailler tard le soir je mets des
coudes s'imposer enfin vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
comme beaucoup d'entre nous j'ai
commencé en bas de l'échelle
et puis j'ai monté les échelons au fur
et à mesure plus j'avançais dans ma
carrière
plus logiquement j'avais des gens sur
marais sous ma responsabilité
évidemment pour en arriver là
au quotidien il ya les réunions qui
s'enchaînent les déplacements qui se
font de plus en plus fréquents les
sollicitations permanentes des collègues
et des supérieurs hiérarchiques
il ya le téléphone qui restent allumées
en permanence sans parler de la boîte
mail qui tout le temps d'aborder la
société nous fait croire qu'être une
femme au 21ème siècle signifie être top
sur tous les fronts alors on y croit et
moi je n'étais pas à l'exception donc
j'ai commencé à piocher du temps dans
mes soirées et dans mes week-ends pour
soi disant rattrapé le retard accumulé
et moi je poussais tellement loin ces
comportements que j'ai arrêté d'écouter
les signaux de fatigue comme encore
m'envoyer j'étais tout le temps
irrité j'avais perdu ma patience et ma
motivation elle été réduite à zéro
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour mon corps et ma
tête mon littéralement lâché je fais ce
qu'on appelle un burnout
ça a été une expérience forte et
éprouvante pour moi mais comme on dit il
faut parfois toucher les fonds
pourraient bondir
alors je peux dire que ce burnout
aujourd'hui m'a sauvé la vie
car il m'a permis de m'embarquer dans
une des plus belles aventures de mon
existence
la renaissance de moi même j'ai un boeuf
j'ai enfin pris du temps pour moi et
pour mes ressources et j'ai appris à
mieux écouter mon corps mes envies et
mes vrais besoins
et puis quand je me suis sentie prête
j'ai décidé de mener une vie en harmonie
avec mes valeurs et mes convictions les
plus profondes
j'ai commencé par intégrer une
organisation suisse qui avança vers de
la jeunesse et je me souviens que
pendant mon recrutement au lieu de me
demander quel cet ami diplômés domaines
d expertise
on a juste demandé et toi bibiana qui es
tu mais quel bon question
en fait je m'en doutais bien qu'il était
possible de s'épanouir dans le travail
sans savoir à s'épuiser mais alors mon
passage par cette formidable
organisation man a définitivement
convaincu
j ai découvert qu'un nouveau modèle
d'organisation est en train d'émerger
dans le monde et paquets dans le milieu
associatif
on dit de six organisations qu'elles
sont inspirés ou libérées elles partent
du principe qu'elle et mende est en
profonde transformation et quel modèle
d'organisation actuel ne sont plus en
adéquation avec la complexité des enjeux
de notre époque et je ne parle pas
seulement des l'intelligence
artificielle ou des la robotisation non
non je parle aussi de nouvelle
génération qui porte aujourd'hui des
valeurs différentes que celles de l'osce
anciens
le monde de nos jours émouvant et vivant
il évolue très vite et de façon parfois
surprenante
le monde et nos organisations sont
complexes mais encore faut-il avoir un
chef pour appréhender et traverser cette
complexité dans les organisations
libérés ont fait confiance à l'auto
organisation
pour illustrer cela je vais vous
raconter vite c'est l'histoire des
familles sa vie est une entreprise
française qui fabrique des boîtes de
vitesse et d'autres pièces détachées
pour l'industrie automobile
elle a été fortement frappée par la
crise dans les années 80 notamment à
cause de la concurrence de la chine
les patrons un bon jour arrêt dans
l'usiné il monte sur un banc et il
demande à tous ses salariés dès l'écouté
il exprime que pour pallier la crise sa
raison lui dis c'est qu'il fallait
dissocier les intérimaires mais sont un
obstacle lui disait aussi que cette
décision méritée une réflexion avec les
gens directement concernés il ne se
sentait pas maître de la décision
et puis il se dit que peut-être à
plusieurs il serait plus intelligent
alors les solutions n'ont pas tardé à
émerger au bout de quelques heures
seulement un plan de réorganisation a
été construit avec les salariés et bien
tout simplement parce que ces salariés
refusaient de mettre à la porte
une partie de leurs collègues étonnant
n'est ce pas prenons un autre exemple
chrono flex chrono flex est aussi une
entreprise française qui travaille dans
la dent les dépannages et la maintenance
industrielle et là un thème est les
chemins de la libération notamment suite
à la crise économique de 2008 pendant
ce processus là les patrons s'est aperçu
que son management avait instauré un
climat de peur et de méfiance entre ses
salariés et pour remédier à cela
patrons et salariés ensemble on décidé
de mettre fin au signe du pouvoir oui
vous avez bien entendu les signes de
pouvoir les places de parking qui était
entièrement réservé à la direction le
bureau du patron qui se transformer un
espace de travail collaboratif
puis la confidentialité de l'information
se transformer en un climat de confiance
et la transparence
les équipes c'est son drap organisé
d'une telle façon qu'elle est management
intermédiaire n'a plus été nécessaire la
peur et la méfiance ont laissé la place
au travail autonome et responsabilisant
ce qui est important à retenir dans
l'auto organisation c'est que ce n'est
pas du chaos
bien au contraire certes on lève la
hiérarchie mais ça la place on pose un
cadre c'est-à-dire un ensemble de règles
et des procédures propres à chaque
entreprise et qui sont concertées avec
les salariés et c'est ça ce qui va leur
servir de guide pour la prise des
décisions qui va être de façon autonome
par la suite grâce à l'auto organisation
on arrive à conduire des réunions rapide
et efficace on apporte de la souplesse
et de la clarté dans des procédures
internes qui sont parfois il nécessaire
chez ou fauriat cette organisation que
j'ai intégré après man bernard août ont
commencé leur réunion par un tour
d'inclusion un tour d'inclusion c'est un
petit moment de partage où l'on est
invité à exprimer son état d'esprit
à cet instant précis et plus je
pratiquais le tour d'inclusion et c'est
quelque chose que j'ai fait encore
aujourd'hui plus je me rendais compte
que ces petits moments de change était
loin d'être anodin dans les entreprises
libéré on enlève les masques qu'on a
tous tendance à porter on se permet
d'être soi même au travail
de la même façon qu'au nez à la maison
avec les amis ou même pendant nos
activités de loisirs c'est parce que
justement c'est dans ce contexte-là que
l'on n'est en capacité de donner le
meilleur de soi même dans les
entreprises libéré on prend conscience
que dirigeants et salariés sont des
êtres humains avant tout des gens qui
ont des qualités et des défauts de peur
et des aspirations de doutes et des
rêves et même des difficultés parce
qu'en fin de compte c'est ça la vraie
vie n'est ce pas la société valorise
certains traits de caractère comme la
force les courage et la détermination
mais c'est la tendance à oublier qu'elle
en pâtit la bienveillance et encore la
tendresse sont tout aussi importantes
pour le bon fonctionnement d'une
organisation tout ça peut paraître
difficile voire impossible à mettre en
oeuvre mais des études on le montrait
que lorsque les organisations franchise
n'est pas la libération
elle se porte mieux financièrement et
humainement parlant
certes ce n'est pas sain schéma facile
elle ça peut prendre du temps mais on
peut commencer déjà par des gestes
simples
par exemple en encourageant la culture
du feedback constructive entre collègues
ou encore un s'accordant à toulouse le
droit à l'erreur comme une opportunité
d'évolution et d'apprentissage un autre
aspect de la libération
c'est la raison d'être aujourd'hui on se
posait plus en plus la question que
l'essence de notre vie est bien dans les
organisations
c'est pareil et c'est même vital
l'entreprise américaine patagonien qui
fabrique du matériel technique pour les
sports de montagne en est un exemple
depuis sa création dans les années 50
elle s'est fortement engagée dans la
protection de l'environnement
à tel point que ses convictions et ses
valeurs sont entièrement en craie dans
leur culture d'entreprise l'ensemble des
produits sont fabriqués avec du matériel
recyclé et éco responsable
les salariés ont le droit de s'investir
dans sa danse dans des associations
environnementales pendant deux mois
chaque année aux frais de l'entreprise
et encore elle encourage ses
consommateurs à utiliser le produit le
plus longtemps possible et même à les
réparer si nécessaire
mais sa raison d'être
va encore plus loin car elle est
reconnue pour être une entreprise où il
fait bon travailler
la raison d'être et l'expriment nivéales
en but ultime qu'elle cherche à
atteindre
elle fait office de toile polaire qui
est là pour inspirer et pour motiver
aller de l'avant elle est présente
partout de la moindre petite tache
jusqu'aux projets les plus complexes et
ambitieux accorder de la place à
l'autogestion tendre vers une plénitude
des dirigeants et des salariés et donner
du sens et de la cohérence aux
organisations ce sont les trois piliers
de la libération d'une organisation
je vous ai cité quelques exemples
d'entreprises libérer ou envoient des
libérations mais dont les manques il y
en a bien d'autres qui essaient de
suivre ce même genre de trajectoire
donc pour inciter quelques-unes il y à
netflix michelin harley davidson
zappos ce gore-tex kiabi morningstar la
chaîne hôtelière accor
enfin la liste est longue et bien un
nouvelle calédonie oui un nouvelle
calédonie il ya des entreprises qui se
sont elles aussi engagées dans le chemin
de la libération
adieu les heures et les horaires des
bureaux fixes et les réunions
interminables les congés n'ont plus
besoin d'être validé par un supérieur
il suffit juste de s'organiser avec ses
équipes en interne et le tour est joué
il y en a même qui ont augmenté à 6 au
lieu de cinq
les nombres des congés payés par an dans
ces entreprises calédoniennes le repos
elle et bien-être des salariés est tout
aussi important que le travail ce n'est
pas
étonnant que la sieste la méditation le
yoga est encore la détente par le jeu
ils soient autorisées
le chemin de la libération a été pour
moi une révélation est un moyen de
rebondir face à l'adversité
il a eu un tel impact dans ma vie que
j'ai décidé d'en faire mon métier
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'accompagner
les organisations à s'épanouir
enfin assez libéré alors je me permet de
partager avec vous quelques pistes de
réflexion
si vous êtes un chef d'entreprise je
vous invite à poser les lâcher prise et
à faire confiance à vos équipes
imaginez comment votre quotidien
pourrait s'améliorer si vous passiez
moins de temps à décider et plus de
temps à juste écouter c'est que votre
organisation envie de venir
si vous êtes un cadre ou un manager je
vous invite à pratiquer la gratitude et
la reconnaissance au sein des recettes
qui est ce que vous avez déjà remarqué
les biens que ça fait lorsque nous fait
un compliment sincère pour un travail
bien fait et enfin si vous êtes un
salarié je vous invite à ne jamais
sous-estimer les signaux de fatigue de
votre corps plus vous attendez pour y
rémédier plus les conséquences seront
importantes pour que notre société
c'est transforme nous avons besoin des
citoyens et de citoyennes qui soit bien
dans leur peau des salariés heureux et
épanoui sont aussi des parents qui
auront plus de temps et d'énergie à
consacrer à leurs enfants
en rentrant du travail les soirs alors
si nous essayons dé transformer nos
organisations
nous avons une chance incroyable des
construire ensemble un nouveau projet de
société
alors qu'attendons nous pour saisir
cette chance
merci
[Applaudissements]